- I heard that she's studying French.
Is that true?
- She's studying everything.
She's studying literally two hours
of duo lingo a night.
- I heard it was duo lingo.
I love doing I'm doing Spanish.
- Yeah she's doing French.
- Okay.
I've tried that
- Como estas? Esta bien?
- Asi, asi, un poquito. Yeah,
I'm still, the owls very angry with me,
but I'm doing it. Yeah.
(Audience laughs)
- If anyone asks you
if anyone asks you how you're doing,
Como estas? Say I think
it's okay for woman
to say no, no no. A toda madre.
- A toda, everything.
- A toda madre.
- What does that mean? Everything?
- It literally is like a complete mother
but when you say it, oh, women giggle.
So I'm thinking that maybe
it means something else.
- Now I'm gonna ask Robert my hair guy.
Okay. You've just given me something fun.
Yeah. Okay.
I like it.
Have you learned any French
since she are around
each other all the time?
- No. No.
You said no.
- No, no.
And then I even get that wrong.
How to say no
- But then she does that two hours a day.
Then she goes and gardens for a while.
Then she writes music with
her Nashville buddies.
Then she reads scripts.
She is,
- She is living her best life.
- She is.
- Are you that outgoing?
- She's living her busiest life.
- Yeah. Are you a busy,
do you like to keep busy?
- No.
- Oh, you're chill.
- I mapping is
my forte.
(Audience applauding)
- I am amazing at it.
I told my daughter, my
brother taught me this
cuz he's 10 years older than me.
He used, he taught it when I was a kid.
And he was like, you wanna
play the pan backwards game?
Cuz I was a hyper kid and he
was 10 years older than me.
And I was like, what's that?
I was like, you're gonna
play a game with me.
And it's nap, pan backwards, is nap.
And so I started using it on my children
and they don't think it's funny.
Do your kids do your kids?
They don't think I'm funny anymore.
Do they? Do your kids
think you're funny still?
- My kids stopped,
they're in their forties.
- Yeah.
- They stop thinking
- And they don't, it
didn't come back around.
I don't have that to look forward to
- Grandkids.
- Oh okay.
- Okay. I'll be cool to them.
- Yeah. Yeah.
My forte was when silly, inane,
stupid things made them giggle.
- Yes.
- And then all of a
sudden they reach the age
where they're going, that's stupid.
- And it's like, it's heartbreaking.
- That's all I've got.
- I have nothing left.
- I'm a silly man that's it.
- Oh my God. That's heartbreaking.
Wait, so is it true that your wife
she said that you're a
bit of a hypochondriac.
Is that true?
- Her word
- Her word.
- See people call me this too.
But I don't think I am.
- No, no.
We take interest in our
bodies in what's happening.
- Why is this hurting?
- Yeah.
- There's gotta be a reason.
Thank you, Trisha listening.
Everybody says I have an ailment.
I'm like, no, there's
something that could be
wrong. This shouldn't be hurting.
- Exactly. If you cut off your hand,
you go, whoa, my hands cut off.
And I don't worry.
- Cause you see
- Because, I see it.
And I know what it is.
It's the pain that I don't understand.
- Yeah. It worries me.
And then they always tell you, oh you can.
If you catch it in time and I'm like,
how are you gonna catch it in time?
If you don't check out everything.
- Yes, exactly.
- Yes.
- They're like, well, if you
would've caught it at stage
and I'm like, well, I thought
it was just a headache.
You know, I freak out.
I might be a hypochondriac.
It's fine.
But I good.
- Fact you were loving talking about it.
- Yeah.
- Means we probably are
- I do the body intrigues
me. It's interesting.
So wait, what was it like growing up in?
Was it Flagstaff where you grew up?
- Yeah. Flagstaff.
- I heard that your dad
was an archeologist.
I just find this interesting
in that maybe he was
like Indiana Jones in my head.
That's where I went.
What's real?
- Kinda he was the director.
He was a PhD taught
then became the director
of a museum and a research
center in Flagstaff.
- That's cool!
- Yeah. It was really cool.
It's one of those small but really
well respected museums
cuz it was in Flagstaff.
Which is the peak San
Francisco peaks go up to 13,000
and then within an hour
and a half theoretically
you could be at the bottom
of the grand canyon.
So you had every kind of geological
an anthropological archeological.
- Yeah.
Paleontological.
- All kept in everything.
- yeah, so a lot of scientists,
from all over the world would be there.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah. It was cool.
Did you think it was cool
when you were younger
or you think it's cooler now?
- Yeah. Well, yeah.
I mean it was fine.
I, it just went over my head.
- Yeah.
I play because we were outside of town.
My friends were Hopi our Navajo kids
and ranchers sons and daughters.
So yeah, I was jumping
on horses and riding
in that direction or that
direction for far as I wanted.
Pretty much.
- Did you like riding?
- Yes. I loved it.
- Yeah. Did you ride full
on saddle or bareback?
- My, I learned saddle, but my father said
you're not allowed to
ride alone with a saddle.
Cause the fear is,
- You get dragged by your foot get caught.
- You fall off get hooked
in and that could kill you.
Whereas falling won't.
- Have you fallen from Horse.
- Yeah.
- Me too.
- How old were you when you fell?
- Well, it was a few years ago
(Audience laughs)
And it wasn't,
a tall horse
and I wasn't thin
and it was a lot like gravity
a lot was happening and I
went down and turns out.
I mean, I hurt my butt so hard.
I hit so hard on the
side and my butt so hard.
Oh, I didn't know how to properly fall.
- Yeah.
- But my stepdaughter
at the time was there
with her friends and I
was like, be cool be cool.
And I'm wanting to just ball.
It hurt so bad.
And I'm like, be cool.
Getting it back on the horse.
I got back on the horse.
Cause they were like, you
gotta get back the horse.
And I was just so distraught
and then they were like
it'll be fine.
Months later
I find out
cuz I'm like this isn't going away.
My tailbone
is completely bent
perpendicular to my spine. Like it bent,
- Whoa.
- Like it was a big fall.
- You don't have to be a hypochondriac,
to know that's messed up.
- I know, but they kept
telling me it'll bruise.
Exactly.
(Audience cheers)